Right,
so there was a new article,
I think it was published in nature,
I'll try to find the link for it.
It's about a year old that,
that was based on high resolution
imaging of new connections.
It's actually reviewed and Kurt Sal's
Kurzweil's book.
How to build a mind.
I think that's the name of it.
Um,
and so it turns out that the Cortex is
made out of these columnar structures
that are pre-organized units of neurons
and they're replicated across the entire
cortex.
Basically the same structure.
And like the,
the,
the older,
let's say connectionist idea was that
neurons that fire together wire
together,
right?
That,
that's happened.
Of course that's pretty standard
neurology,
but the,
the columns are already pre wired,
so it's actually columns that fire
together,
wire together,
but there's.
But there's even more with the high
resolution scanning.
So it turns out that underneath the
columnar structure,
there are these prebuilt highways that
are connected,
connective tissue that are pre,
pre prepared.
So the columns have the option to
connect to the,
to the underlying highway,
and that highway can connect other
columns.
So it's as if implicit in the brain
organization,
and this is at the cortical level,
say nothing of subcortical organization,
there's already preexistent uh,
uh,
likelihoods that certain neurons will
fire wire together.
Yeah.
So,
and,
and what else is cool is that this is
actually architecturally quite a
regular.
So they found that the,
these superhighways arranged in lines
and,
and in,
at right angles to one another.
So it's almost like a three dimensional
structure of why your cubes that
underlies the neuronal structure.
So that's some neurological evidence for
the archetypal idea.